time to make the donuts Duncan has long
said it's on time to make donuts who
else goes to that trouble but it's not
just pastries over at 70 plus years
Duncan has repeatedly spotted and
adapted to new trends even when that
meant focusing Less on donuts donuts
literally used to be part of their name
and now it is not and it definitely
reflects how their sales have really
changed and how beverages become so much
more important than just selling Donuts
from 2009 to 2019 a time when Duncan
introduced many drink options and
rebranded it grew from around 6 000 to
over 9 000 locations
the shift away from donuts and towards
drinks is just one change that has
helped the company evolve from a New
England Diner to a worldwide chain worth
around nine billion dollars
this is the economics of Duncan
in 1948 restaurateer William Rosenberg
opened a diner called open Kettle in
Quincy Massachusetts selling coffee for
10 cents and donuts for five two years
later he changed the name to Dunkin
Donuts inspired by seeing others dunk
Donuts into their coffee it was one of
the first Trends the company capitalized
on Donuts were actually served to troops
during the wars behind the American
lions in Italy a brief interlude and
good old-fashioned donuts and when
troops came home it was the 1950s and
people were going back to offices and
donuts were a really great way to
quickly have breakfast on the go and
Dunkin Donuts really capitalize on that
Duncan the magic munchkin The company
took donuts a step further in the early
1970s when they introduced the munchkin
as a way to use the leftover dough from
the center of donuts this is what a
munchkin looks like they help them down
to Dunkin Donuts in quite a few flavors
Donuts continued to be Duncan's Focus
through the 90s when Trends began to
shift in the 1990s 2000s America was
generally becoming more health conscious
and donuts for all their tasty goodness
is not really known as a very healthy
breakfast alternative so companies like
Dunkin Donuts need to think about what
else could they serve meanwhile
Starbucks really was starting to take on
the U.S at that time and was expanding a
lot and what they were doing was
inventing new kinds of drinks customers
were looking for caffeine and a lot of
it the number of U.S coffee houses
doubled between 1996 and 2001. so after
Decades of focusing on Donuts in 2006
Duncan made one of its first moves away
from the pastries when it introduced the
slogan America runs on Duncan coffee and
beverage sales were popular for Quick
Service restaurants since they have
better profit margins than most
offerings like food
when you think of a breakfast sandwich
or a baked good that involves labor it
often involves many different types of
ingredients it might involve some kind
of packaging whereas Coffee at its
simplest is just coffee in a cup the
labor tends to be less and that does
make it more profitable generally for
these drinks by 2011 Duncan was selling
more hot and iced coffee than any other
fast food chain in the U.S including
Starbucks in New England and New York it
had 57 percent of the fast food coffee
Market at the time Duncan had 6 800
locations around half the amount it has
now and bigger changes lay ahead in 2018
Duncan's Rebrand and name change to go
by just Duncan was a big step that year
beverages made up 60 of Duncan's sales I
think one of the important things to
recognize is caffeine is addictive and
Everyone likes their morning coffee and
that is a ritual so people often go to
get coffee every every morning where
they might not necessarily get a donut
every morning or some kind of food to
give customers more options for their
caffeine fix Duncan continued to expand
their drink menu releasing espressos
cappuccinos lattes and americanos take a
sip of you got this with Dunkin espresso
drinks and in doing so it went Toe to
Toe with Starbucks Duncan is really
trying to in some ways get into
Starbucks's Lane they've offered a lot
of different new kinds of beverages they
invested in machines to offer espresso
they offer cold drinks they offer
Blended drinks and they really are
trying to I would say compete more with
Starbucks whereas Starbucks probably
still thinks of itself as singular after
the push for more drink sales in 2019
Duncan was one of the top coffee sellers
of Quick Service restaurants selling
around 1.6 billion hot and iced coffees
in 2021 Duncan sold over 4.4 billion
cups while caffeine is a big seller
Duncan's drink Focus isn't just on drip
the company said that highly visual
beverages are a focal point of its menu
they've also launched more specialty
drinks like matcha and chai between all
the flavors and coffee Blends they've
added nearly 50 new menu items in the
last four years but on the food side of
the menu the brands struggle during the
pandemic when the breakfast category was
hit hard by commuting changes caused by
lockdowns Duncan's decline in sales
would have been nearly five percentage
points larger if temporarily closed
stores were included in those numbers
but once again hot and cold drinks with
their High profit margins continued to
be top sellers on the menu earlier in
the pandemic these cold drinks actually
were real Saving Grace for a lot of
coffee chains in part because people
would order them in the afternoon it's
really created a new day part for them
where they didn't have it before and so
that's been really helpful for them when
breakfast really took a hit early in the
pandemic around that time Duncan was
releasing new drinks for example in 2020
Duncan announced the new Duncan
refresher and this summer they came out
with three iced pumpkin drinks and a new
flavor of refresher cold drinks really
have exploded in popularity including
during the pandemic and a lot of it has
to do with social media with Tick Tock
70 of sales for a lot of these chains
now is these cold beverages which is a
huge amount of growth in a very short
amount of time
as beverages continue to grow more
popular Duncan's experience in
developing Buzzy drinks may help it
create more in the future Duncan
certainly has changed from the 1950s
when it was just known as a coffee and
donut company they've expanded their
drinks they've expanded their food and
thanks to franchising they've expanded
their location so I do think they've
evolved a lot from their from their
roots in Massachusetts as obstacles
caused by the pandemic continue to
challenge companies across the board it
remains to be seen of Duncan's history
of evolution will continue
foreign
[Music]